La huge announcement I am shooting my
special Wednesday December 14th here in
Los Angeles at the dynasty typewriter
theater go to ryansickler.com for
tickets use code sickler you're gonna
get half off tickets all right please
come out I want the place packed we're
doing two shows and I want all the die
hards there all right screw the industry
this is for the fans go to
ryancicler.com get your tickets today
Chicago I'll be there November 11th and
12th Grand Rapids Michigan December 9th
and 10th get your tickets to those shows
and all shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media and we're going to start
this episode like we start every episode
by saying thank you very much you guys
are the [ __ ] we're into the 200 episodes
now
this community has not stopped growing
um so thank you and if you're watching
me tell you this right now hit that damn
subscribe button okay it is a free way
to help the show and uh it's simple to
show your support that way all right and
if you gotta have more then you gotta
check out the patreon it's called the
Honeydew with y'all and I highlight the
low lights with you all and I know I say
this [ __ ] every week but I can't
emphasize how [ __ ] wild we just
talked to a guy the other day that was
dead for three and a half minutes three
and a half minutes because a truck
crushed him and pushed them into some
water and His official cause of death
was drowning okay that's the kind of
[ __ ] you're getting it's five dollars a
month there's no other tiers it's five
bucks a month and if you sign up for a
year you get over a month free all right
you're also getting this very honeydew a
day early you're getting it ad free and
you're getting it at no additional cost
all right sign up today if you're on uh
or use me if you're home when I'm on
tour a couple more dates coming up we
got Chicago and uh Grand Rapids and also
I will be shooting my special here uh in
Los Angeles at the dynasty typewriter
theater Wednesday December 14th go get
your tickets on my website
um and if you use code sickler you will
get half off your tickets all right
let's pack that [ __ ] out and have some
fun all right that's the biz y'all you
know what we're doing over here
highlighting those low lights these are
the Stories Behind These storytellers
and I am very excited to have this guest
here first time ladies and gentlemen on
the do please welcome Kurt Brown all or
welcome to the Honeydew hurt God it's a
good intro it's a good intro congrats on
the special I didn't know your recording
that's awesome finally thank you very
much nice I love Dynasty typewriter it's
awesome yeah I love that too it's like
good for Jamie and everybody in the
community they made there and Sandler
comes through like it's a it's a
fantastic place no it's really great
um speaking of specials let's go bro
yeah baby you can promote everything you
got
I got a new special called perfectly
stupid comes out October 27th on moment
so moments like this you know kind of
new way to watch a special you know that
lives there for two weeks and uh you can
watch it there for two weeks after that
it comes off there you can't see it
there anymore and it'll go to like VOD
and stuff like that so you'll be able to
see it like you know but it'll be more
expensive when it goes to VOD so watch
it now October 27th on moment uh you can
just Google Kurt comedy I'll be there uh
and uh yeah and then I'm you know my
podcast bananas you can always listen to
that strange news and personal stories
it's fun I love it too yeah
um well I said to you outside that you
know we ask all our guests to just throw
some log lines of what they think they
might talk about and then we get to
whatever we get to it's just it's just a
thing that yeah in case we need to come
back but you just have one simple
[ __ ] thing on there and it's an
unfortunate thing that made me laugh out
loud but you wrote we're gone with dead
mom
[Laughter]
I was like listen to how he responded I
read it I guess it's gonna be it's gonna
be uh interesting so
um tell me before we get into that where
are you from originally like let's get a
little background on your family and Mom
yeah yeah so I'm from New Jersey
um I was born in Michigan actually
um but my parents got divorced when I
was two
so moved to Asbury Park New Jersey and
uh and then grew up next door in Neptune
for my whole life
um
I've never heard of that yeah yeah it's
right it's like you know 10 minutes from
the beach in Central Jersey
and um yeah single mom
uh raised me and it was kind of a weird
life because it was um
you know my dad is a surgeon so he had
this other family he's a he's a hands
he's like a bone surgeon okay so he does
hands and hips and knees but mostly
hands and now he's retired but um so he
was you know he is a wealthy man uh and
he had another family my I also have
like eight brothers I have seven
brothers I have seven siblings holy [ __ ]
really like from four different wives on
my dad's side this is all Dad yeah it's
all dad mom is just you and Mom well
we'll get to that that's actually fair
enough but starting off yeah starting
off whatever is your mom an affair no no
they were married so he's been married
to all four of them I see he's on his
fourth wife now but my like eldest
sister is 60. and myself he's constantly
doing surgery
hahaha
why did you learn to fix that Dad [ __ ]
those hands have my heart Steph
can you show up a hug for Christ
oh man
no instead he's just doing surgery
looking over at the next nurse this is
gonna be the next one
you have to hurt Tracy that is such an
insane way to live your life so uh so
yeah so then I would you know my mom was
a pediatric nurse
um so we didn't have a lot of money
um my dad had a lot of money so then I
would go visit him and I would live this
insane life where we would like travel
and do things together the man
forget man the doctor who repairs hands
makes way more money than the nurses who
take care of babies yeah and who are
there all the time he literally walks in
he walks in does a 10 minute interview
and then walks out and goes to lunch and
they are there and and now it's 12 hours
no nurses work 12 hour shifts but back
then it was eight hours or you have to
work out overnight and stuff
and so a lot of times my mom didn't have
like a babysitter or anything so I would
just go to work with her because of the
Pediatric floor
um and that was crazy oh just like like
be on the Pediatric floor all the time
the like the play Lady taught me how to
uh to play gin rummy you know they would
give me I remember they would give me
this job all the time how old are you
like six years old okay but how were you
when your parents split two two okay all
right so now you're six and you're going
to work with Mom yeah I'm going to work
with Mom they'll give me a job
um to deliver blood to the lab yes I'm
not kidding like a push cart or
something no like a [ __ ] bag of blood
they would yes yes I'm not kidding to a
six-year-old because this is pre this is
before AIDS you know so like no but
anybody could talk
[Music]
so like literally and you could smoke in
the hospital still they didn't I don't
remember that yes they didn't make it
illegal in Jersey they didn't make it
illegal in Jersey until like the night
1990 but at at the place where she
Monmouth Medical I think it was 83 that
they made it so literally a nurse who
was smoking a cigarette would hand me
just a hot bag of blood samples oh God
that's gonna make me sick
I was expecting cold for sure it's fresh
out of somebody in that it's behind the
curtain right here oh man and you would
take it where I would get well I got to
take the elevator which was very
exciting do you know like that's what
that's how old I was taking the elevator
was [ __ ] pushing buttons cool yeah
pushing buttons and the lab was in the
basement
and I remember her come out of the
elevator and to go right would go to the
lab and to go to Left would go to the
morgue yes swear to God and I would get
confused I was six years old so I had
been inside the more like multiple times
before I was like seven years old what
do you remember seeing it's just a bunch
of doors on the wall you know what I
mean like I wasn't seeing my bodies or
nothing like that no I don't know I just
like you just like walk in you're like
that's not the lab because the lab
you're not allowed in there's like a
dark what was it what did it look like
or bright bright you know and just you
know doors yeah file cabinets in the
wall
uh so yeah so then I would like you know
just hand the hand the blood to someone
at the lab and then just like walk away
you know it's just crazy that that
anyway so yeah I kind of grew up on the
Pediatric floor and my mom and I were
just like super close obviously
um
uh you know only child as I thought
um and
and then you know I went to school in
Baltimore yeah I wore this for you today
by the way oh nice from Baltimore or not
to your Hopkins yeah I'm gonna try it
we're gonna try and get back there and
do a we're trying to get do you remember
there there's something we've been
talking about on our podcast do you
remember this IMAX movie the Beavers
IMAX movie that used to be at the
Baltimore Science Center yeah oh yeah
yeah at the science center yeah yeah
that IMAX and it was like beavers like
eight feet tall and I remember seeing it
when I was like 19 or something and
there's a scene where like the Beavers
[ __ ]
and it's like they're it's like
four-story tall beavers [ __ ] each
other and it's like all these children
and it's like what this is crazy
so that's why that's what we're doing on
my podcast we're gonna try and get them
to bring the Beavers back to that island
and Maryland Science Center is like
totally down they're like we'll do it
that's great
so yeah grew up with my mom
and probably around I don't know it was
like October October 2015 I was like
driving I was on my way to uh I was
doing like a somebody wrote a pilot and
who I didn't know but they asked me if I
wanted to be in this pilot you know it's
it's free where you know you're just
hoping that maybe it gets picked up
but it's you know two you know 12 or 16
hour days that you're doing for free and
I was driving towards there my mom calls
me and she tells me that she has like uh
of liver cancer that she just just found
out and she had no idea she just like
gets her liver tested because she takes
like some medicines that like affect the
liver and um
and it's this crazy specific I guess all
cancers are specific but this is like
hey I just got that General cancer yeah
you're going down here for the general
cancer
but it's called bile duct liver cancer
and it's very rare and uh and at the
time what I didn't realize about like
the cancer world is now they like
they I don't know at least this is the
doctor that she had wouldn't like give
her
you know like you have three months left
to live he wouldn't give her a date
because they found I think from studies
that if you give a person a time limit
they're most more likely to just die
within that time limit because it's like
they give up they give up they have like
convinced themselves the opposite not
going out Buckwild like wait what I'm 80
000 in debt you know like I just went
out and went great for three months
exactly what I would do I'm like well
I'm getting into heroin first and
foremost I'm gonna start smoking again
let me I'll take the fentanyl on my ride
out that's gonna be the last thing I
want to see what the buzz is all about
so she told me and uh so she's just
finding this out and she just found out
she it was like a routine test she had
just been a little tired is this
genetics I yeah I guess so I mean I have
no idea it's like how old is she when
she finds us out she finds out when
she's 7D
71 or 72 okay
so it's a rare bile cancer and so it
rare liver cancer okay and also she
never drank my whole
childhood she never drank at all like
there was never liquor alcohol in the
house I think there was Sherry like when
I started like trying to find you know
liquor to bring out in high school I had
to bring Sherry it was just like
disgusting like [ __ ] you're we're not
drinking this [ __ ] you get it it's [ __ ]
again
so yeah so it's this uh you know just
rare cancer and um
and I'm like okay well like do you want
me to come out and uh she's still in
Jersey and then and then of course like
I find out and then I have to go work
this job
for two straight days what's your role
I'm like playing like a like a like kind
of a
uh
autistic guy who's interested in video
games like that's what I'm playing
um but it's a comedy but it's you know
it's I have no idea whatever happened
with it literally did it and then it
just disappeared Into The Ether you know
I was like oh that was a job that I had
to work when I just found out my and I
didn't tell anybody because I didn't
know anybody on set or anything like
that
and so
about like two weeks later my mom calls
me and she's just like I want you to
come here and I was like okay good I'm
coming and how did she sound
she just sounded tired tired you know
and uh this was I you know because the
thing is like she was a nurse you know
and I think it's worse in some way to
have all that extra information that's a
great point you know like she's a great
Point totally understood exactly what
was in store for her because she'd seen
it so many times before and she knew
exactly what her chances were like it
was stage four hindsight yeah it was
stage four when she found it geez you
know
um but up until then even at stage four
it's not affecting her or did she just
go back and realize oh so just tired
tired I remember she came out and
visited she came out and visited us in
uh the September before one month before
she had visited la
and she would get tired you know like we
went to the beach we took like a a
three-hour ride up to Pismo Beach and
the car ride kind of tuckered her out
and then we like went to the beach for
like an hour and she like actually fell
asleep on the sand I was like oh she's
just getting old you know it didn't feel
exceptionally weird or anything like
that but then um but it's like boom
stage four
and so she started on chemo and I I
moved out essentially moving in with
them I got a place in New York because I
was also
uh doing this TV show that happened to
shoot in New York so it was like very
like it was a blessing to be able to
have money coming in so that I could
support myself and I would just go up
and shoot like a day or two a week and
then come back to Jersey
and so I'm living in this house so my
mom got married again late in life to a
high school sweetheart that's nice yeah
so she got married when she was like 64
65. and also like just [ __ ]
heartbreaking for them or like they like
they were gonna have the rest of their
life together my mom hadn't even retired
my mom was still a nurse you know she's
still working at 72. and I think that
year she was planning our time she was
like down to part-time she worked at a
for a like a doctor's office she was off
the floor
um and she you know she had like she was
all ready to like retire and then travel
and do [ __ ] and you know all that stuff
and um so I moved back I'm essentially
living in this house with her husband
and her she's in bed mostly she's asleep
mostly because it's like the cancer I
mean the chemo just kicks your ass
especially when you're that age and so
I'm just like what do I do you know like
I'm just trying to be uh I'm trying not
to get in his way he's grieving he's
going through his process you know like
I'm sorry I asked you you have an
uncomfortable question sure is he
pulling that step dad [ __ ] on you
he's a very particular guy he's a very
particular bro he's like call me dad
call me dad and I'm like okay
[Laughter]
it's like you won't go fishing I don't
want to go fishing it's an interesting
thing because he's not your father and
you don't really know this guy and now
you're in his space which is also your
mom's space so it's your space and
you're trying to put your [ __ ] together
and your thoughts and grieve what you're
thinking's going on he's doing the same
yeah and you're there yeah he probably
doesn't feel comfortable being as open
and everything with you and vice versa
of course Andy's a man of that
generation I'm just about to say and
those guys don't cry they don't have
feelings they just walk it off they just
walk it off that's 100 there is no
talking about any feelings whatsoever
instead it's let it build up for 20
years and then [ __ ] explode and go
crazy yeah you know yeah but just drive
my car off a cliff one day
you could have just talked to somebody
yeah
and then I remember and so I was just
like I was trying to imagine what could
I do to be helpful and so I was always
you know taking my mom to chemo uh and
then just being there I was trying to
cook dinners you know because she would
always cook it was still again that that
type of relationship 70 year old people
in a relationship where the even though
the woman Works still she still Cooks
all the meals that sort of thing was
like just that 50s mentality so I tried
to like cook the meals I wasn't cooking
things people liked I wasn't cooking
things he liked you know what I mean and
then I was like trying to do the grocery
store shopping there's mashed potatoes
or [ __ ]
and that's not like a bad cook I feel
like I'm a good cook but I'm not I'm not
cooking the things he's used to you know
what I mean yes of course
like I'm not making meatballs or
whatever you know or like meatloaf yeah
uh and so and then I'm going shopping
and I'm like buying stuff and then at
certain point I remember he yelled
he's just like we're never gonna be able
to eat all this food in the fridge
because I just kept buying food you know
I was like didn't know what to do and I
was like this is such a funny thing to
be mad about that we have too much of
the food the things that we all need to
serve over there yeah
but I was like I get it that's him
that's him being like there's a per
there's another man in my space that I
don't really know very well and it was
it was just this weird thing of like two
because she would be up in a room sick
and it'd just be these two men who don't
know each other kind of like gingerly
operating around each other like one of
them fully aware of what's going on and
would be happy to say look man I know
Bubba but this dude doesn't even know
how to begin exactly yeah which is like
no I'm just gonna bark at you a couple
times let you know it's my space too
that's 100 it is it's just like okay now
we're like two dogs now because we're
not gonna use words no we're gonna be
like dogs just sniffing around each
other and barking each other and he
would have this very specific routine he
had a you know I think he was in the
military at some point so I had a
specific routine like he would watch TV
for 31 minutes or something at 7 pm and
then he would move over to the so the
living room and he would read for an
hour and a half or something then he
would go up to his room and continue
reading but it was a specific routine so
I kind of felt like okay at least I know
what's what happens at night after he
leaves the TV I can go watch TV because
he's not coming back he doesn't come he
doesn't come back he stays so room to
room so it's like navigating that sort
of thing and then my mom I think also
was just depressed you know and I don't
think people talk about that
with when a parent has cancer
uh that at least it happened for her and
she was always in a great mood she was
always a very funny lady uh high energy
always helping people
and then she just got like just
sad and and be and then also also the
the once you have the chemo and you have
all those pain medications as well they
just change and that is the saddest part
that it feels like
you lose the person a little bit before
you lose the person man that's well said
you know
um and that that was the toughest thing
I was dealing with so then
you know my mom would be asleep and out
at like 7 P.M so oftentimes I would just
leave and go out to I had some I had a
friend who lived in Asbury and so I
would you know take a car to Asbury and
just get [ __ ] wasted you know on the
boardwalk and uh I remember once it was
like right around
Thanksgiving
and there's this band
um
uh what's the name of that the band
um I can't remember but they would
always play the day after Thanksgiving
and everyone would come and like because
everyone's home for Thanksgiving and
then after it's like all these and it
was like a band that was like younger
than me but I kept going they play Stone
Pony on the Friday after Thanksgiving it
was always awesome and uh River City
extension that's the name of the band
I'm happy to remember they're local I
don't think they exist anymore and uh it
was always like a big party and everyone
loved this band and people just go ape
[ __ ] like local here Hometown Heroes
everybody's back from college or
whatever so there's a younger crowd that
was there I was the old old guy and uh
just got hammered and then my mom called
me and was like we're going to the
hospital and this is like I I got there
in like early November this is you know
this is Thanksgiving right so a couple
weeks and she's like come home and I was
like uh she's like actually meet us at
the hospital I was like okay so then
just [ __ ] wasted like had to get in a
car and go to the emergency room because
she had a fever and if you get a fever
on this specific chemo like you can die
like immediately is that right yeah okay
and so and you know her husband didn't
want to bring her so she was like I'm
going I'm driving myself he just thought
like we don't need to go 7 29 I got two
more minutes it was more like he I think
he just didn't think that it was that it
was necessary but she knew the medical
stuff she's like no it's one it's 102.
yeah it's this chemo he's not a nurse
yeah
and so then I'm just like in the ER with
them just trying to be [ __ ] normal
and I'm just so drunk uh and it was just
like this is crazy and then we were
there for eight hours so then I start
going like getting less drunk less drunk
then getting hungover and then you're in
the hospital and your mom's sick and
it's just like oh I've made everything
so much worse
made everything so much worse by trying
to like just have relief for like a
couple hours
who the [ __ ] would think that I'm gonna
be spending the next few hours
recovering in the hospital yeah exactly
um so it turns out it was it was okay
they made sure she was all right they
got her fever down she went home the
next day so she was right to go though
yeah she was right to go they were like
you're it's good but you're all right
um and then during this time I um
my buddy's uh Emily and Kumail Kumail
nanjiani and Emily Gordon uh had had
written this you know this movie The Big
sick and then they were they they there
was a part for me and and I had read for
it but I didn't think I was gonna get it
uh and then during this time I also find
out oh you you're in you got it and
it'll be shooting in New York and I was
like oh this is amazing but I'll be in
New York at the same time so I can still
be with my mom and that was much later
that was like in May so I was I had like
jobs in New York which was great but
it's still again I never talked to
anybody on either of these shoots so I
was like going to work so I would leave
New Jersey take the train in go to work
tell no shoot I'll tell no one wow and
then come back yeah no I it just didn't
occur to me that like so who were you
talking to about this who was your
outlet my wife okay my wife Lauren and
she's being supportive she's back here
so she's back in LA but then no around
right before
um uh right before Thanksgiving she she
wanted to come out but we have a dog
um it was like a you know 40 50 pound
Mutt and uh and so she was gonna drive
out with the dog and our car so then we
would have a car there and the dog would
be there and then she could stay with me
uh which is it's just so huge I mean man
yeah what a partner yeah for real like I
always like I was like oh she's the one
you know like when she was able to do
that I mean we were already married but
you know now I was like now we're gonna
stay married
[Laughter]
and I remember I love her she made this
the the this so her mom and her mom's
wonderful as well and has been she lives
out here with near us now too
but she flew out so that she and Lauren
could drive the drive together cross
country with the dogs
um but it was you know November or
whatever and they decided to drive the
most northern route
and I was like why are we why are we
going north most northern route in
November so it was like they got like
stuck there was snow it was just like
yeah yeah 80 was just closed you know
and then they had like White Knuckle it
through like this insane drive that they
had all the while like trying to get
there to like to my dying mom
and then during that her grandmother
becomes incredibly sick and then I
believe her grandmother died during that
time and so she had to literally stop
and go to Chicago and then be in Chicago
with her grandmother oh man
I mean it was it was it was insane all
this was happening at the same time so
then she gets out and then we're all
together which is great but it is you
know it's just that's that's that chemo
thing especially with a an advanced
liver disease is uh it's just a losing
game you know the housing market has
been nuts for over a decade but it's
finally moving in favor of first time
home buyers competition is less Fierce
and in some areas prices are finally
dropping 2023 is your year start
planning now so you can take advantage
you know I keep recommending the how to
buy a home podcast because host David
Sedonia has helped thousands of
first-time homebuyers all over North
America figure out their own path to
home ownership since 2005 David has been
the Undisputed first time home buyer
Authority bringing his years of
experience to help you take advantage of
every housing market the number one
mistake he hears is that people start
planning too late David can guide you
through those next steps whether you're
planning to buy a home now or five years
from now he can even connect you with a
great realtor in your town that works
with first-time home buyers and actually
cares about you plus he just released a
first time home buyer starter kit and
how to buyahome.com it's a free resource
with all the knowledge you need to buy
your first home start planning this
holiday season at how to buyahome.com
and make this the last year you rent
find how to buy a home on YouTube and
wherever you listen to podcasts if
you've got family and friends coming for
the holidays then you're already
anticipating that oh my gosh do I have
enough food feeling it's not fun but
there's no need for it Wild Grain is the
first bake from Frozen box for artisanal
bread so you'll always have
crowd-pleasing bread rolls pastries
pastas and more in your freezer while
grain uses only clean ingredients and
utilizes a slow sourdough fermentation
process that's healthier for you and
tastes better than anything you can find
in a grocery store every item bakes from
Frozen in 25 minutes or less this
holiday season while grain is featuring
delicious new limited time sweet treats
such as pumpkin cinnamon rolls orange
cranberry biscuits and chocolate
Avalanche croissants all you have to do
is sign up at wildgrain.com Honeydew and
choose which type of box you want to
receive and how often it's easy to
reschedule skip or even cancel the bread
and the pasta is all amazing but I'm
telling you that once you try those
croissants you will be ordering more
they're flaky fresh buttery and they
leave your house smelling great too
hungry already for a limited time you
can get thirty dollars off the first box
plus free croissants in every box when
you go to walgreens.com honeydew to
start your subscription you heard me
free croissants in every box and 30 off
your first box when you go to
walgreens.com honeydew that's
wildgrain.com honeydew or you can use
promo code honeydew it checkout it is
too nice out to be too damn High just
because we've aged out of summer break
doesn't mean we don't need to chill out
ditch the munchies paranoia and potency
of today's weed with that grass dag
grass is legal organic Kemp that relaxes
your body and Mellows your mind that
grass CBD products are made with 100
organic hemp that's easy to dose and the
effects come on smooth they offer a
variety of products from their smokable
pre-rolled joints which I love as well
as hemp flower and variety of CBD
tincture drops enjoy the effects of CBD
while keeping a clear head all dead
grass products are federally legal for
ages 18 and over and it ships right to
your door anywhere in the U.S whether
you're looking for a new Buzz or a chill
way to enjoy an old favorite that grass
will leave you in a euphoric mood go to
daggrass.com honeydew to check out their
products right now that grass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to daggrass.com
do go to daggrass.com honeydew for 20
off your first order that's daggrass.com
honeydew now let's
do the dip so you so you said November
and now it's May
so six months into this yes I'm doing so
she had she did one drug and then she
took a little bit of time off
um because the drug stops working at a
certain point you know the chemo you you
get it until it you you do a session and
her her tumors had gotten smaller okay
so then she was off of it and for those
like
couple weeks when she was off it were
amazing
she like started to come back to herself
and everything and then then you just
start dreading the the next doctor's
visit and then we go and then we she has
to be put on at something new
uh and so then they're gonna try that to
see because it started growing again can
I ask when you say something new is it
new for her or is she trying any
experimental medications or drugs or
anything no it's just it's just a it's
just a news yeah it's like okay so we
did this this one stopped working now we
go on to this next one and if this one
and then the understanding is if this
next one stops working then there's not
really an option after this you know
that's like kind of the understanding of
it uh so then you're like you know
you're kind of in the home stretch
unless some miracle happens but at stage
four it's like the Miracles you're just
holding it at Bay
and
um and then so then so so let's jump
back like
I don't know eight years prior to this
or seven years prior to this
I my brother has he's about to have his
first kid okay so my half brother and uh
he asked my dad because I was born at
home were you really yeah I was born at
home during an ice storm because my dad
was sorry you weren't like an underwater
birth at home or anything like that this
was like because you couldn't get to the
hospital no I think my mom wanted to do
it at home she was weirdly she was a she
was uh she's a nurse yeah yeah she was a
nurse and I think just really got into
like the the 70s idea of like all this
new research was coming out in the 70s I
think about like the breastfeeding is
good and like home births are good but
it was very new do you know what I mean
like even now it seems a little strange
uh but yeah born at home my dad helped
but it was during a nice storm
and so my brother asked my dad he's like
how was Barbara able to have a kid at
home I thought you could only have a kid
at home when it was your second kid
um and my dad was just like having a
drink drunk and and he was just like a
barber had another kid before Kurt and
uh and Walter was like what and then
she's like Yay in high school
and then and I was like and so then we
then my brother was like sitting on this
information for how long I don't know
like maybe a month or two and then he
came to visit me because he wanted to be
in person and then we got drunk just a
series of drunken Revelations and then
we got drunk and he's like so Dad said a
weird thing
I know it's like he's like Dad said that
your mom had a kid in high school and I
was like no that's not true that's
insane she would have told me uh and so
then he's like yeah he's like but that
said that that's why you know your mom
had it you were able to be born at home
and I was like oh yeah why what real
quick with that why can you not have the
first kid at home it's just because you
don't know if you're gonna have
complications I see okay once you've had
one kid yeah once you've had one kid
successfully the second birth is
typically it's just like usually easier
it can you know go south at any you know
all those things are difficult but it's
like it can be easier
and so then I sat on it for like a
couple of months
and it's just that [ __ ] Catholic
thing
of this like how do I bring this up this
is hard to talk about I don't know how
to talk about this because
um but what you're bringing up is just
asking your mom you still don't have any
proof yet no proof yeah I just have my
dad saying it and
um what a moment dude right here I gotta
say like your your mom's
slowly passing yeah you're dealing with
that and right before this happens you
just get dumped on that your mom had a
kid in high school where is this kid so
it was earlier it was before she got
sick actually that I that I got this
information okay so we jump back hold on
to it I held on to it for a couple
months and then we had lunch
at this Greek restaurant in Manhattan on
the far west side a thing called Uncle
George's it was just like a Greek place
my mom really liked Greek food and we're
just like eating lunch and I was like
okay here's when I do it you know like
so did you have a kid before me you
dropped it like that yeah I mean I mean
like I was just didn't know what to do
speaking of Uncle George's uh who's my
brother's Uncle
you know the one you had in high school
Amaya let's be Uncle George am I an
uncle
so you're just sitting there eating and
you say yeah did you have a kid in high
school yeah and my mom was just like oh
yeah like it was nothing like it was
nothing crazy isn't that crazy I'm
expecting a jaw drop a holy [ __ ] moment
here yeah and I said I was like what and
she's like yeah and I was like why
didn't you tell me she's like I've never
told anyone
and well obviously my yeah my dad just
because of the the birth stuff but so
then so where's this kid so this is a
whole long story this is so uh all I
know is it was like she was she's like
all she's like when I was 16 I got
pregnant
and I was Catholic so my mom sent me to
live with these nuns
and I had the baby there and it was
given up for adoption and then I was
sent back and everyone yeah and everyone
pretended like it didn't happen
everyone just pretended like it didn't
happen when she came back and she was 16
years old and they gave the baby up they
gave the baby up for adoption
and also all I know is that she's 16 she
went with nuns and then the baby was
gone and she came back and no one ever
talked about it and no one's ever seen
that kid and no one's ever seen that kid
I hope that child's alive so so so then
while she's sick
my feeling is like I want to bring this
up
um while she's sick
should be like maybe because then I had
asked her do like do you ever want to
get in touch
um with him she's just like no I I just
worry I'm just scared you know it was
just like all that Catholic stuff of
just being like I don't know and she's a
child yes and she's 16. imagine go back
16. we'll learn how to stop at stop
signs yeah
I'm excited about having sex and my her
hair is purple yeah yeah yeah she's
having a [ __ ] kid yeah
who gets taken from you yeah and her mom
and what about her mom and dad they were
okay with that that was like so her
dad's never been around
um I think you know my grandmother got
my grandmother was a dancer she was a
ballroom dancer so she taught she
performed and taught ballroom dancing
and so I think she got pregnant and uh I
think he offered to marry her and she's
like I'm a dancer hit the road pops you
know yeah and so then my mom was born
and she essentially gave my mom to her
mom my mom's grandmother okay who is a
wonderful woman who weirdly ran a
speakeasy in [ __ ] Pennsylvania in the
middle of the woods in La during
prohibition that's bad yeah and I have
the invitation for the day it opened it
was called yeah yeah it was a call it
was called the black cat uh and it's
they said the black cat a good place to
prowl I just love that pretty good
[ __ ] and it's from 19
37 I think oh yeah
um and so I that and that was the
Invitational like come it was like a
supper club where you go and then they
give you booze and uh so totally crazy
so anyway then she buys a house in
Asbury Park my mom moves in with her so
my grandmother pretty much raises her my
great-grandmother
uh but anyway so I'm wondering like I I
feel like I need to bring this up to my
mom
because like maybe before you die do you
wanna want me to try and find him you
know can I ask you this too I
is part of you torn because I I feel
like do you feel betrayed that she never
told you or or after what hearing what
happened do you feel sorry for your mom
you know and now you want to help her
instead of uh confused and angry like oh
[ __ ] you were a kid and your baby was
taken from you yeah no I I think at
first I felt maybe betrayed
but now I've done a lot of research into
it I've written a whole movie about it
actually wow
um because these things were because I
started after my mom died I was like I'm
gonna find this guy
and I had just no idea how to start you
know all I knew was like nuns and like
again that Catholic way like very small
details were given to me I knew she was
16 I knew that nuns took her and that's
it so I was just like for you know just
loss I called her best friend who she
spent like every day with she had no
memory of her leaving for three months
she had no memory I called her brothers
her brothers had no memory of her just
disappearing for three months like when
I taught when we talk about like I think
they were lying to you think that they
were they did not know when I told them
that she had a kid everyone was shocked
even our own brothers and our own well
her brothers were four years younger so
they were like 12. so they're just like
jerking off they're like I don't know
what's happening and uh her cousin
didn't know so I called her best friend
that she had her whole like you know her
the last half of her life didn't know no
one knew she never talked about it at
all just it's like just this complete
repression complete Catholic just denial
that it existed I think just to like be
able to function and so I started going
like researching and it wasn't until I
found this book called
um
the girls who went away uh which is an
amazing book and it's all these
interviews with women who were taking
two maternity homes they're called
maternity homes that's where I got the
word maternity home okay I didn't know
that that's what it was called I didn't
know that either I was looking for like
orphanages I was looking for uh convents
that took in women
so what happened pre-roll versus Wade
like uh if you got pregnant and you were
sent away for the last two months of the
pregnancy you lived dorm dorm style in
just a bunch of beds the photos from
these places are [ __ ] terrifying it's
just like it sounds like that what's the
show on Hulu oh uh yeah yeah the
handmaid stuff thank you yeah dude
that's what I'm seeing in my mind when
we say this [ __ ] yeah it's just like a
bunch of like 16 and 15 year old girls
pregnant scared they don't know anybody
there it's all these numbers yeah
friends right from there
and that and then reading all these
stories in this book really made me
realize what was happening like no one
told them what would happen to their
bodies no one told them what birth was
like no one told them that they had a
choice whether they could talk about
nuns they probably have no idea because
they've supposedly never had sex right
exactly but they've watched these girls
give birth like a hundred times they've
watched it yes and so it was just like
this very alienating time and then they
they essentially like you give birth and
then your baby's taken away from you and
you just never see the baby again you're
sent home and you got like they're
oftentimes forced to sign the baby away
um and they do like it was crazy it was
so insane it's crazy it was crazy and it
happened all across America like we
think of that that it just happened in
like Ireland or whatever like no it was
happening here
and there was Catholic ones there was
non-catholic ones there was Jewish ones
there was all like different you know I
just learned about when I was in
Edmonton and I'm don't remember but they
did the same thing there with the um the
native people they just buried their
kids and [ __ ] and they're trying to
speak up you're like hey hey hey this
has this happened that was in
Pennsylvania was one of the states that
um I have an older cousin she's in her
late 70s she was more of like an aunt
growing up you know what I mean she's a
she's a whatever my dad's first cousin
but I've always challenged her on this
[ __ ] and then when the keepers came out
we're all Baltimore I'm like do you
remember this she's like I don't
remember it I go they're showing news
clip so it was on then she goes look I'm
not denying it it's clearly it's on a
friend of mine that I went to high
school with her husband
um is related to the guy who they
believe killed the nun well it's his
uncle by marriage his aunts the blood he
divorced him
um my mother
knows um his best friends with the woman
who knows Jane Rowe and there's a Jane
Doe and a Jane row and I was like you
know that lady you're that close to that
she's like yeah and she's they telling
me these things a guy I went to high
school what's up Tony santofani his mom
sold a house to the nun who holds the
story holy [ __ ] and she went to school
there and she said whatever happened to
sister and she said I don't know what
you're talking about
so there's this whole thing and then
right at a few months later uh my cousin
she sees this whole thing happening at
the Catholic church in Pennsylvania
where they started to come down yeah
she's like Ryan and she tells me about I
go I'm [ __ ] telling you yeah and it I
watched her old
I love cath Catholicism mine start to
explode and be like I can't deny it like
what the [ __ ] yeah no I mean like I've
definitely seen
uh you know family members who are in
like after specific specifically after
the keepers came out just be like I
can't go to church anymore you know
we're gonna like get my kids uh
Christian christened
um and I was like I don't think I can
just sneeze on them yes
it's safer
oh man
[Laughter]
man I did not know this story was gonna
take this kind of twist dude yeah it was
insane so then I was after and there's
no 23 year me like he's not out there
trying to find out so I did 23 or me
that was like my first go and 23andMe
takes a while you know it takes like a
couple months results that person also
have to enter their [ __ ] and if they
don't right yeah
um
and so once it was when I found this
book that I was like okay so
I knew it was Catholic and I knew it was
a maternity home so then in the back of
the book it has uh this organization
Catholic Charities that is the one now
because they were like sued at like the
[ __ ] Catholic so the Catholic Church
used to have all the records locked down
no one could access them I was like go
[ __ ] yourself we're holding all our
secrets and then they were sued so many
times in the 90s uh that they finally
there's a law in New Jersey I think it's
National maybe that you have to you have
to be able to put parents with children
uh if you if you if if they want to
so then I got in touch with Catholic
Charities Catholic Charities is like
give me your name you have to prove that
she's dead so I'd like send her the
death certificate and then they knew
that I was the only living you know you
know you know uh son of her and they're
like then I have certain rights to be
able to find about the only air you can
go do whatever yeah yeah and so uh then
you're like get in touch with Trenton
Catholic Charities and so then I'm
literally emailing yes the world takes
bro I got some family up in Trenton bro
it is the most terrifying hard food for
people who don't know Trenton just has
painted on a giant Bridge Trenton makes
the world takes and I don't know
it's so Jersey it is just like well we
just keep taking it but also just keep
making it you keep taking it and then
the best part is that like the
industrial uh like uh economy in Trenton
collapse yeah
nobody's taking anything from Trenton
anymore it's like it was probably pretty
good when people were taking from
Trenton wasn't it now what do you got
you got it took everything that's
because you took everything
yeah I know Trenton so I'm like
literally emailing with this I I'm
assuming she's a nun you know
and she's like your mom is in our system
and I was like holy [ __ ] this has been
like years okay of me trying to track
this stuff down and uh and then you have
to like it's like a hundred bucks or
whatever like send a check and then send
the death certificate send all this
information and then it's like it
there's two weeks between every email
you know because I think she's just one
person in an office like answering
hundreds of emails
so it's like two weeks between
and then they're like we found after
months of interacting with this woman
she's like we found your brother no way
yeah and she's like why don't you write
a letter to him
you know as an introduction then we can
send him the letter and then he can
decide whether or not he wants to be put
in touch with you so I don't know his
name I don't know anything about him so
I write this whole letter you know and
like trying to explain as best I can
what happened although I don't really
know you know I'm just like making
assumptions and uh it's like three days
later I send her the letter
three days later she calls me on the
phone and she's like I am so sorry this
never the first thing we do when we
search for someone is we search for an
obituary and if they don't have an
obituary the next thing we do is we
search property records to make sure
that they the person is somewhere in the
United States there was no obituary for
your brother and there's and he has a
house in his name
and so we assumed he was alive but we
just found out that he died oh yeah and
he had died before I even found out he
existed he died like 14 years prior do
you know how
um I I like the the details are a little
wouldn't that be a public record now to
a death certificate it's public yeah I
guess so I maybe I could get that death
certificate
um but there was no obituary published
um I know he died in his sleep
um so I got in touch with so then I had
to like rewrite my letter he's like she
he has a he has a surviving Widow you
can send that letter to her if you want
and so I like rewrote the letter and
like sent it to her we kind of had some
emails back and forth and I find out I
have two nieces holy [ __ ] hold on a
second yeah and this is wild because
this you say he died 14 years ago so
This Woman's been dealing with life
after him for 14 years and all of a
sudden his brother [ __ ] pops up yeah
get the [ __ ] that's a lot dude that's
intense right and you find out you have
two nieces two nieces How old uh they I
think are like 22 and 21. wow yeah yeah
are you okay so do you go see what
happens so
um I I'm you know I exchange a couple
emails with my I guess my sister-in-law
and then uh they are just like my my
daughters would love to be in touch I
was like yeah let's get some emails
going I start emailing with them or
emailing back and forth
um one of them's name is Ariel and I had
been writing a script uh
and this whole time I've been so I sold
a show to CBS during this time and I was
writing script one of the characters was
Ariel I just kept had been writing Ariel
into a script over and over and over and
over again and then all of a sudden my
niece is named Ariel it was like crazy
um that is cool isn't that weird yeah
and so I'm just gonna start writing 50
million dollars 50 million dollars
that's all good that's all it takes
that's crazy I've been wasting all my
time I know what the [ __ ] am I doing
right in other words wild so
they both are they uh they say we want
to come visit and I was like okay come
on out and visit so they actually see
your comedy or anything at this point I
guess I sent them my like my website so
I guess they could see some things you
know so I have no idea how much they're
familiar with and they come out and they
are the two coolest people they're so
down to earth super chill and so kind
and wonderful and I just saw like I just
saw Arielle when I was in Philly and I
saw Ariel and her mom they both came to
my show did you get emotional when you
saw these girls oh yeah it was like
crazy you know it was like not only that
this is your this is from your mom yeah
from my mom this is from these are girls
from your mom yeah it's totally and it's
like it it and I'm so like it's it was
it was so wonderful to get me emotional
what's your mom's grandkids that's your
my mom's grandkids you put it all
together yeah and it was like that was
the craziest part
um but yeah I just saw her and she's
doing great I saw one of them and
totally crazy but also during so then my
mom so and my point is I'm so happy that
I did not bring this up to my mom when
she was sick because if we had gone
through the process and found out that
he was dead like I think it would have
just been like the you know the straw
that broke the camel's back so I'm happy
that it it it worked out the way it did
but then
my mom all she wanted was grandkids she
was a pediatric nurse all she wanted was
grandkids she just loved children she
loved children so much she was so good
with them she was such a great mom to me
and so Lauren and I are there
and we're like we gotta we you know we
our plan was to have kids but it was
like well now now that's pushed up a
little bit like we got to do it now
and so for the entire time my mom was
sick we're trying to get Lauren pregnant
and and it's just like you know it's
like you know you do all the programs
you're hearing tons of Stress and
Anxiety so much stress and anxiety also
so much drinking yeah because it's just
like every night you're just like it
when you're like that yeah it is and
then uh and then we were doing this uh
podcast for audible called wedlock where
we would it's all about marriage right
and one of the segments we wanted to do
was on these bonobo monkeys do you know
about bonobos so bonobos are like
they're very close to chimpanzees
um so they look kind of like chimpanzees
but while chimpanzees are always
fighting it's a patriarchy and they're
just always fighting each other at all
times uh bonobos are a matriarchy and
they're just [ __ ] all the time so
they just they [ __ ] like 38 times a day
damn and they do it for like you know
like if the like The Matriarch comes
over like you're eating a a banana and
she wants the banana she'll come over
and like take it from you but to say
sorry she'll [ __ ] you a little bit
that's nice it's so crazy dude it's like
it's oral sex it's [ __ ] it's like
full penetration sex and they're just
constantly [ __ ] each other and being
like sorry it's my turn to eat this and
like eat it would it be like to be
living in a matriarchy I got I gotta
wonder
you want to have my salad
so that's how everybody like stays cool
by a sex right it's crazy it's
fascinating who's gonna be riled up and
so we we're gonna go record this so the
only place we could find who would let
us record their bonobos boning was uh
the Jacksonville Zoo in Florida
Jacksonville so we so this is while I'm
on sick we fly down to Jacksonville
we get there that night go to bed wake
up at like five in the morning because
it's like you have to go during the
feeding first first thing in the morning
they're first feeding that's when the
majority of sex happens because that's
when the majority of resources are are
there the I.E the food right so it's
everybody's eating and everybody's
giving diddle in each other to make sure
everybody feels okay about stealing food
from each other so we go and just watch
bonobos [ __ ] all morning long
and then we're like [ __ ] they're like
well the zoo hasn't opened yet you want
to walk around we're like yeah we'll
walk around and then I remember my wife
is like trying to take a picture there's
a Siberian tiger who just keeps pacing
in his pen and Lauren's just trying to
get a good video of him like coming by
again and uh and she's just doing it on
like the third round it just comes stops
turns around and then just sprays all
over her oh no yeah just it got her it
just expressed all over her you I just
I'm like over here taking a picture of
like something else and I just hear oh
hahaha
[Laughter]
anyway listen I didn't know they could
do that either till I took my daughter
to the San Diego Zoo and there's a sign
that tells you it can go at least like
five feet it tells you to stay it's huge
but there is
terrible that's disgusting it's so
upsetting
and it's just hormones you know what I
mean it's just like they're just
spraying hormones and so anyway there
must have been something good in it
because then we came back she obviously
took a shower uh and that was where my
daughter was conceived in Jacksonville
it's a bad hotel right after watching
bonobos [ __ ] her getting sprayed by a
uh by a tiger
uh and I know it was them because that
like we had to have sex that weekend
because of the whatever it was and uh
that's hilarious
and then
um and then we're just like waiting and
waiting and waiting and it's like before
my my mom's like close to dying and
Lauren goes out and gets a pregnancy
test and it's negative and we're like
you know deflated it's like another
month you know been trying for like
eight months now and uh like deflated
that it it didn't work and you know I
tell my mom like you know we're gonna
name we're trying to have a kid and
we're gonna name her after you
and my mom dies on July 6 2016. okay and
then you know we had the funeral so it
was like you know a week after that we
have the funeral
and uh and obviously we've been drinking
our faces off
and it was the week it was the day after
my mom's actual funeral like we had the
wake and then the funeral the day after
Lauren just like fell off so she took
another pregnancy test she was pregnant
it had been a false negative no way so
she we found out she was pregnant the
day after my mom's funeral how about
that yeah dude life and death [ __ ]
crazy that's crazy yeah it was just like
and I remember I that I took a
photograph of like the moment because I
just was like this is we're in this
house in Asbury Park you know that we
rented we're literally moving it we're
tape we're moving out of the house
because we're about to go back drive
back to uh la
and uh yeah massive and then you know
and as you know like you become a when
you become a parent
all you want to like all of a sudden you
see your parents as human beings for the
first for the first time really in your
life you're no longer
a parent-child relationship you're like
parent parent
and I had and my mom was a pediatric
nurse you know
so it's just that situation of like
every moment of my daughter's life I've
always wanted to ask her a question
about this was I like this what would
you recommend you're a pediatric nurse
what's wrong with him you know like I
mean real Source not just a parenting
hindsight but a real possession a
professional I would have had a [ __ ]
nurse she would have flown across
country and be like well I have a nurse
who lives with us
yeah yeah and so it's just been like
that crazy thing and I say talk about
this in my special a little bit but like
that I've been you know I've been
parenting without the parent that raised
me and you know that's just like this
like weird strange vacuum you know of
always missing her yeah yeah
so the Sun that you're that was taken
from your yeah
gave her what she wanted and the one she
raised just just dropped the ball in the
grandkids ah bro
I'm the grand kid front I really failed
one day later a false [ __ ] good day
after the day after and I remember it
was at the funeral
um so the day after then that's that's
the day of the funeral right or the day
after the viewing day after the funeral
and I remember it was like at the
funeral we're having like the little
party get together after at the house
and Lauren had a glass of wine and then
everyone left and we went to the beach
and she was like she couldn't walk and I
was like what the and I was like I
remember being like mad like why did you
drink so much you know she had one glass
of wine and it was just like her body
being like we don't do this anymore she
could like she could hardly walk she was
like in the ocean I was like I gotta
take you home I like took her home and
like she just went to bed
and then the next day she went to bed at
like 4 P.M or something and slept all
the way through and then and I think all
like in the next day she was like I
think we gotta go get a pregnancy test
and yeah and then we got to practice I
was like what this is [ __ ] crazy this
is insane
um with your mom were you able to have
any conversations before she passed
you know it's like
what'd you guys talk about
it was tough because she was always so
in pain
I remember
towards the end I mean it was like a
week or so before she died
uh
me like just crying and you know I was
just kind of losing it which I would
typically not do because I didn't want
to put more stress on her
and I remember her just being like
you'll be fine
no wait
you'll be fine and I understand what she
now that I have kids I do understand
what she means she's like she's like
you're gonna be okay you know like and
so but I do remember right before
jit like there's the the pop you know
like like a couple days before she died
she just had like a lucid day and a
bunch of family were over and everything
and she got to spend
a day where she was like talking and
verbal and we're like rubbing her feet
and everybody spent the whole day with
her and then the next day it was like
boom unconscious and then it was just
like waiting for that
and
at a certain point the hospice nurse
like called us in
and then it was like literally her
husband and I were on either side of her
bed and then that's when she finally
went so it was like Lauren was at the
foot and and and and her husband and I
were on either side holding both hands
and it was almost like she waited he
wasn't like Swan
it's for me
you know but everyone had to have like
their time can I ask you because yeah
this is a thing so there's two ways you
know while there's more than two ways
but there's
watching someone you love go slowly and
painfully and then there's the other way
where someone calls you and says you
know Dad's dead you're like what you
weren't there yeah do you
do you have a preference would you do
you listen I know it's an ugly question
but I'm glad you got that that even
though that time is not a great time are
you glad you had that time yeah it's an
interesting question and uh the thing is
is when someone's slowly dying you go
through the grieving process while
they're alive
and so then by the time especially with
cancer by the you want them you like you
want them to be relieved of this pain
and so it's a relief when they die but
then there's that weird guilt about
feeling relieved that your mom's dead
you know so then you're dealing with
that but at the same time you are you're
allowed to process it with the person
who's dying and so I think that that
might even though it's [ __ ] horrible
you at least are able to have an
acknowledgment say I love you that sort
of thing you know the suddenness one I
think you process for much longer
because of its suddenness and because
like who knows what the last
conversation you had with that person is
you know and so
yeah they both suck but you kind of it
happens in real time with when the
person's sick you know and at the point
was your mom ready
she wanted to she wanted to go like she
was she wanted I actually called uh she
asked me like she's like I want to go to
sleep and I don't want to wake up
because she knew that that was she knew
once hospice was involved they have the
drugs they can make it happen you know
because the hospice usually lasts like
you know a couple days when they're at
that point she's gone off her her chemo
there's no coming back we know she's now
gonna die and she just said to me I want
to go to sleep and I don't want to wake
up and uh and uh and that's illegal in
New Jersey can't do that I think it's
legal now but you have to is that right
there's there's seven states where I
didn't know that where uh assisted
suicide is okay but you have to like go
through so many red tape bureaucratic
steps to get to it it's insane they make
it very difficult most people are
probably gone by the time they say yeah
exactly or next to it and so I was
trying to figure out I was like that's
she knows what's happening she knows
what the future lies for her she knows
what's possible
and so then I started researching it and
then her husband was very angry that I
even brought it up with him and he's he
said to me which was insane he said if
you do that I'll call the cops and I'll
have you arrested
um and I was like okay just eat the food
[ __ ] just he just feed the food
that's how you get rid of food
I'll help you do that you know and I was
just like wow really [ __ ] insane you
know like what an insane [ __ ]
response she's just in pain like let
she's gonna die in a couple days why not
make it so that she can peacefully go
now right I'll have you arrested so that
your mom can die in pain alone yeah
exactly
food out
and so I actually called Doug Stanhope I
don't know Stanhope at all but he had I
watched his special
um and read his book digging up mother
where you know he helped his mom commit
suicide and so I I got his number from
Brenda Walsh and I was just calling I
was like hey man you don't know me I'm
so sorry but like how did you do I
wanted to know like the actual details
of how you do it and he's like well we
had a nurse that was like helpful and I
was like I don't have that and he's like
yeah I don't know man uh but he was very
kind to take the call yeah and then I
called up an anesthesiologist that was a
friend of a friend and I was like so
tell me how do I do it and he's like I
can't I'm not I can't tell you I can't
tell you how to do it like legally I'm
not allowed to tell you how to do it and
I was like yeah but she has morphine
like we can like how much how many drops
like what what what it will do and he's
like I can't I'm sorry and so we're just
like locked in this thing I felt like
completely helpless
and felt like she was suffering
and felt like I was gonna get the cops
called out yeah I did it I'd be scared
to Google search it yeah right yeah
because then they just go to your
computer but he just looked up right
here how much more Mom I just looked up
wait did you actually write how do I
kill my mom you know it's not specific
to moms or not
like how to kill a person would be
normal
or your mom yeah yeah
oh man and so then yeah so it was just
like that you know that whole thing at
the end where it's like you wait for
them they're they're urine to stop
coming you know that means that they're
you know circulatory system is shutting
down and then it's like you just wait
for systems to shut down which seems
insane to me like and now I feel very I
have a very strong feeling about
assisted suicide now because if I get
cancer I want to be I want to have a
[ __ ] Choice yes I want to be able to
say like all right this is I'm gonna
have a big party and then I'm gonna die
as opposed to going just being in pain
pitiful and withering away and
excruciating pain and causing I mean how
much does that cost PS a family yeah you
know to watch a loved one die who don't
even want to go like that yeah who
doesn't want to go and they and you
change and the drugs change you and
you're not really like the person you
were you're not talking you know it's
like we we prolong that that last part
of life because of some concept of like
a hypocratic but also our selfishness
yeah it's our selfish yeah that person
wants to go yeah and it's self it's just
an interesting thing someone told me if
you really think about this like when
that person dies you know no this is no
disrespect you lost your mom your mom
lost everyone yeah yeah and if that
person is saying I want to go right then
you should let that person you should
respect it this isn't a this isn't a
young woman who's about to commit
suicide because she's depressed this is
a lady who's lived her life in a disease
has taken over her body she'd like to
check out once you have a terminal
illness it should just be an option for
everybody across the board so you'll be
the guy that probably knows this then
it's legal where Amsterdam isn't it like
the Scandinavian countries there's a
place in Switzerland where it's pretty
okay again it's like you know they they
want to make sure that your family's not
pressuring you and to do right people
are flying over to Switzerland to die
and they're just like yep yep yeah yeah
exactly to get people's money so there's
all these legal things but it can be
done correctly and respectfully
um have you ever seen You Don't Know
Jack the HBO movie no you should watch
it oh really it's uh Pacino Jack
Kevorkian oh wow but it's intercut with
real
um interview footage and
um stuff like that to help the story
along so that you see these people
there's home videos of people who submit
to him and say look this is what I'm
going through there was a woman that
told her husband I sat outside today for
10 minutes and I didn't know where I was
yeah and if that happens again for 30
minutes it's over yeah I don't want to
[ __ ] I don't even know where I'm I am in
my own backyard yeah so then it was them
pleading to him to come and it's it's
great you should watch it I will I will
I just listened to this uh I think it
was on This American Life or it was
maybe on Radio Lab
um but about a woman who went with her
husband her husband had dementia and so
they flew to Switzerland and he ended
his life before before he was incapable
of authorizing it like that you have to
get that kind of like sweet window
because once you're too far gone with
Alzheimer's they're like we can't he's
not in his right mind to be able to
authorize this so he like he he made the
choice and then it was just about them
getting over there and it's it was
heartbreaking and fascinating and yeah
it's a great listen so how are you
dealing with it now especially as a
parent you're raising you have two girls
no no no no no boy well like boy and a
girl and uh oh man it was just the other
day you think you're you think you're
you think you're you've dealt with it
you know and uh yeah you think it's done
do you think it's like I'm okay it's
been yeah it's been six years now
and uh uh Olive got her
photos from school back so she had
picture day and I'd literally looked at
that it was like it's it's exactly my
mom and she's named after my mom so her
name's Barbara Olive my mom's name was
Barbara Barbara Jan and uh and it is
exactly my mom and you know the kids are
there like Olive's behind me Gus is
watching TV Lauren's my and I just boom
like just picked it up boom started
weeping and then like trying to keep the
kids from seeing it like well what a
crazy thing for like a five-year-old to
be like look I got some pictures from
school
Jesus he really [ __ ] hates you yeah
I had a moment with my daughter that I
just would have never seen coming but I
have a picture of my dad and my grandmom
together and my dad he died when I was
16 years one of him on the dresser yeah
this is like she's eight now this is
probably when she was like four or five
and she takes the picture and she just
looks at it and she goes dad I miss my
grandpa and starts crying and I know as
a father she's probably looking for that
come here it's all right yeah I do too
oh my God bro we went together now
holy [ __ ] I'm like you didn't even know
oh my God I can't believe what's
happening right now I thought I dealt
with it oh man [ __ ] surprises you and
then it brings up new [ __ ] yeah and
you're like I haven't dealt with it yeah
not all of them it's an ever going thing
of trying to be a better person a better
man a better parent a better partner
yeah yeah I say it all the time yeah I
mean you should look back on yourself
and go what the [ __ ] exactly what was I
thinking like there's me today's me
would go back and fist fight a lot of
versions of me and say shut the [ __ ] up
you don't that's great again God damn
yeah right exactly if I was still like
nope knew it all at all yeah you don't
want that [ __ ] hell that guy's that
dude's unbearable right now yeah
well dude thank you so much for uh
coming on and sharing this thank you I
did not see this coming man this was a
wild twist and turns in there yeah thank
you for having me you're welcome and
before we promote your special and
everything again
um advice you would give to your 16 year
old self I don't like to hear what you'd
have to say advice I give to my 16 year
old self would be just to uh
I had this idea I think that uh just to
start writing right now like immediately
because I had this idea because I just
did improv for seven years I started
doing comment I was 22 but I didn't
start doing stand-up till I was 29
because I just kept saying to myself
like well when I have something to say
I'll write it and it's like that's not
how it works you gotta start writing and
then you figure out what you have to say
um so I would just make myself start
writing earlier
um not funny just uh just things like
just writing no just write a comedy
start writing like just start writing
things right like make things I was
always like
that inertia took so long for me to get
over I mean I also have I had a bag of
handwritten notes of jokes I've never
even used them yeah throwing them all
away whoa cause I look at them like
that's it's garbage but what it was this
is exactly what you're saying it was a
start to it was a beginning framing my
mind in a comedic way I mean you're good
enough or you look back and go no but
you see what you were trying for and
stuff and yeah you're right get started
yeah just started just starting
um again thank you and please plug
everything you have uh my special is
called perfectly stupid and uh it's just
all about becoming a dad and dealing
with my mom dying and uh and having a
dad who's who's uh who has many children
for many different women and yeah you
can get it on moment moment.com for um
October 27th to like November 10th or so
then after that look for it on video on
demand awesome yeah
um as always is Ryan sickler.com Ryan
sickler on all your social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]